ha pound some earn the a back on
neck get dirt and grenades no way I can
hear that song to not think of die hard
with a vengeance it's just that
unanimous right that's pretty much the
entire world also yeah thought sup die
hard with a vengeance so die hard with a
vengeance is the third die hard movie
and to me I think it's a really good
return to form great one actually is
directed by the guy who directed die
hard 1 and where as die hard 2 was
bigger but not better die hard with a
vengeance is bigger not saying it's
better than die hard because it's not
but it is still great this broke some
ground for the die-hard movies you know
instead of being locked in one location
John McClane is all over New York City
and this review is going to be totally
spoiler heavy there's no real way to
talk about die hard with a vengeance
without ruining some of the plot points
just the way it is the way the movie is
constructed you don't die hard to I was
like what are the odds of the same thing
happening to the same guy twice and die
hard with a vengeance there is actually
a story-based reason for it the bad guy
in this movie is played by Jeremy Irons
and he plays Simon Peter Gruber yep Hans
Gruber's brother the brother of mr. I
don't know so you know that his
business he's a little more than pissed
off at John McClane so he's gonna mess
with them before he kills them yeah he
has his broad scheme going on also but
killing John McClane is he says it's one
of life's little bonuses and he really
makes McClane squirm too he has to go
around all these locations and solve a
riddle on a phone or a riddle that's a
bomb or the first thing he does to haze
him is he makes John McClane stand in
the middle of Harlem with a sign around
his neck yeah and don't get pissed at me
I didn't make this sign he makes him
stand in the middle of Harlem with a
sign around his neck he had not good not
good to be that guy I got a say of all
the hazing that I've seen of all the
lunatics and movies that mess with some
cop or some person that is the thing I
would want to do the lease I'd be like
oh yeah I'll be Colin Hanks sitting in a
thing of water that becomes acid no
problem whatsoever standing in Harlem
with that sign no not doing it nope and
then they break more ground by giving
John McClane a partner not really a
partner because he's not a cop he's a
Samaritan but it's a me--will l.jackson
samuel l.jackson before he was samuel
l.jackson
this one he was just the hold on to your
butt's guy from Jurassic Park and Samuel
Jackson's pretty intolerant he's really
sarcastic he's pretty much like lack
John McClane who's not a cop who doesn't
like white people you know how George
Bush doesn't
about black people yeah Seuss doesn't
care about white people but we're fine
with it he's he's cool samuel l.jackson
give me the biggest racist against white
people person ever ever like yeah but
it's Sam Jackson so these two are just
on a wild goose chase for this entire
movie and John McClane is trying to
figure out what's why meanwhile Simon
Gruber is just messing with him before
he kills them this dude's a dude with a
plan too he's a really good villain
because the guy is just really smart die
hard movies being die hard movies every
die hard movie has that all right
suspend disbelief kind of going on
this bomb goes off the alarms in this
Treasury are just out of whack and all
these big dump trucks show up and those
guys like hi the mayor told us to come
on over his cops like well you know if
the mayor said then cool come on in
don't need paperwork don't okay well I
guess so I guess nowadays is because
everyone's all paranoid about like
that back in the mid nineties it was
like come on in steal you're not
gonna steal because you said you
weren't going dude this is New York
after all the land of peace but this
movie's hardcore one of the coolest
scenes in the entire movies the elevator
scene where McClane just wipes out a
bunch of guys and that last shot just
blood and brain just goes everywhere is
that morbid side of me is like yes it is
indeed die hard with a vengeance the
endings a little weird for me it's like
they made the movie for Simon Gruber to
get away in the end and I think that
would be awesome
I wanted to see Simon Gruber get away
but it's like when they made the movie
they're like nah he needs to go down so
the bottom of an aspirin bottle totally
blows the whistle on the entire thing
John McClane shows up to Simon Gruber's
place where he has all his gold and he
shoots Simon Gruber's helicopter out of
the air crashes on the ground and
credits done it's like a peninsula of a
movie with a little island at the tip
could you imagine an ending where Simon
Gruber gets away that would be awesome
John McClane's like the brother of
Hans Gruber got me in the end he didn't
kill me but he did win maybe I'm a
sucker for villains who win but that
would be a really good opportunity to
have a villain who won against John
McClane visually since the ending could
probably be phantom edited out so die
hard with a vengeance
is bigger John McClane's in an entire
city now the villainous awesome he's
really smart he's the brother of the
main villain in die hard 1 Bruce Willis
of samuel l.jackson have awesome
chemistry on screen I will say die hard
with a vengeance I would by and did buy
on blu-ray
not quite as good as diehard 1 but
really good it's like the true die-hard
sequel for me right so who is a villain
that you want to see win or would want
to see win whoever
he is or she is comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more